[Musique]
qui est la personnalité du jour
maintenant vous la connaissez c'est
angela merkel la chancelière allemande
qui vous le savez doit quitter le
pouvoir d'ici quelques semaines dès
qu'un nouveau gouvernement sera formé en
attendant un ours en peluche à son
effigie se vend comme des petits pains
de l'autre côté du rhin au point d'être
carrément en rupture de stocks malgré
son prix barrières quand même 1 189
euros quoi le petit ours en peluche
exactement lui mais le dindon arnaquer
on larnack le dindon yan tan hing a
envoyé deux tableaux vie d'un musée qui
lui avait prêté 70000 euros pour qu'ils
reproduisent une de ses oeuvres ces
billets il devait les exposés comme une
illustration des revenus moyens d'un
danois et d'un autrichien le musée
espère et donc obtenir le même résultat
en fournissant 534 mille couronnes
danoises à l'artiste x 72 mille euros
mais le résultat est bien n'est pas là
puisque on obtient des toiles blanches
le musée d'art contemporain a également
découvert au moment de la livraison que
le projet avait changé de nom pour prend
l'argent et cours colère de la direction
qui a tout de même décidé d'exposer son
travail mais elle prévient l'artiste a
beau se défendre de tout vol et évoqué
une démarche artistique il a jusqu'à
janvier pour rendre l'argent sinon une
plainte sera déposée dès toits
judiciaire pour britney spears libérer
enfin la tutelle de son père devant un
tribunal de los angeles avec effet
immédiat c'est à dire que jamie spears
n'est plus le twitter officiel de
britney spears une décision qui a réjoui
les fans de l'artiste venu la soutenir
ça a été des années et des années de
travail et ça ne serait jamais arrivé
sans la sensibilisation du public sur
cette affaire je suis si fier de cette
mobilisation qu'a rendu cela possible
allez
je suis pas comme ça
y est
est ce que c'est possible
une fois sur ce plateau le laisser
terminer quelqu'un une phrase plutôt que
en permanence de la coupe et notamment
quand c'est une femme est ce que vous
pouvez vous tenir et arrêtez vos d'être
des machos des misogynes et bien sûr
voilà l'argument qui tue mais oui elle a
tous les attributs ce qu'on attend de
ces deux de ces jeunes filles un petit
peu fantasmé sublimer vous voyez elle a
un sourire et battant est là elle a
beaucoup de temps à la tête plus de
dents que dans la réalité des grands
yeux bleus maquillée elle à des fins l
année
voilà
voilà c'est au café oui mais c'est moi
qui adore c'est mon look ta customiser
ton tee shirts et ça
ça fait comme la fin de l'empiré découpé
comme ça j'ai trouvé que c'était bien
fins un style s'est trouvé un style
grunge une scène de nu et brigitte
bardot la plus belle femme du monde et
bizarrement ce n'était pas si facile que
ça c'était pas super sic parce que
j'avais peur de bande et un
sparadrap comme un imbécile a rien
empêché j'avais mal on en parle
avec un ami c'est quoi cette histoire
non non non non non non
[Applaudissements]
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disaient à
l'époque oui ça coûte une once de
graisse n'est pas de la littérature mais
là aussi c'est pareil dès qu'on fait
l'effort de lire et surtout que c'est
des pavés comme ça quoi donc il faut
dire non mais faut vraiment
qu'on n'a rien compris et angélique
angélique on a vu où vous nous aviez
bien fait et manier la pelle sonde
régulièrement sans trahir de secret
c'est sur quel type de sujet c'est des
sujets d'action vos tenues sur votre
politique par exemple sur la campagne
non non non non c'est sûr ils
s'intéressent beaucoup je vous dis à ce
que pensent les français à ce que
comment est la situation en france
comment on sent les choses sur le
plateau parce qu'on reçoit énormément de
jaune change ces gens quand on est sûrs
et gilet jaune continue des gens voilà
qui était en détresse il dit comment tu
lis on est ce que il ya six qui vous
regardent nous regarde mesdames et
messieurs les élus de france
je sollicite
votre parrainage
a fait
que présenter ma candidature
vous pensez sérieusement que si je
n'étais pas aujourd'hui le mieux placé
on sait que je serai devant vous ce soir
pour vous expliquer vain pour l'instant
de n'être même pas au second tour un
dans les sondages
[Musique]
d'où tu me traites de fachos dont tu
mettrais regarde les autres gars de voir
des millions par an c'est de faire son
coming out devant tout le monde ah oui
je vais dire 4h au passage toujours
humaniste ça s'est avéré que
la scène se passe en floride où le
reptile se balade dans le jardin de cet
habitant la stratégie adoptée est
atypique mais elle s'avère efficace
autour de lui beaucoup de voisins plus
prompte à le filmer ou à le dessiner
après coup calais b
l'alligator sera relâché un peu plus
loin près d'un plan d'eau
je veux bien me touche attention on va
voir qui va partir on abat n'en faut pas
menacé
des mecs comme toi c'est pas vous avez
vu jordan la racaille n'est pas toujours
là où on le pense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
des points que je peux pas manger et
celle de tous les candidats ça va on a
fait 600 km en voiture avec du poisson
dans la glacière mais aller à la
cueillette dans nos montagnes il a été
obligé de manger ce plat pendant d'aider
des semaines pour bourreau en tentant de
dire que le chef est chez best il est
allergique au boulgour désolé
passez au suivant
osséja si la condescendance du petit
facho juste pour un alias il est décidé
bonjour médard clerc allez c'est bon je
commence à la mort va pas me traiter que
ça
allait au bout pour prouver à quel point
peut-être j'avais touché quelque chose
simplement tous les droits et c'est je
crois que j'étais un peu loin là il va
falloir que nous rattrape
le gros lourd j'ai l'air mais là
maintenant tiens je suis méchant pas
excusez moi je
suis joueur francis vous avez le moins
de la fin mais le mot de la fin pas
d'eux un mot
je veux qu'on soit sincère et quand
l'homme d'honneur ne lâche aucun mot qui
ne partait du coeur mais si molière